okay let's go here with why not d4 hmm
okay well Queens gambit declined it
seems cuz well alright I'm gonna go with
this and try and take advantage of what
this pond right here since it's no
longer defended by the bishop well I'm
already starting to feel pretty
comfortable here because my queen is in
a good spot applying pressure this pond
and there's aa
actually maybe I should have taken on d4
first oh no no no that's okay because
I'm seeing an eventual capture after
there is this capture on d4 if pawn
takes this can still become an issue
pressure by the rooks or if pawn takes
like this then my knight or Bishop could
be making use of b4 so first things
first let's get my knight out now let's
get my bishop out my knight does want to
play to c6 let's get here right now and
I wonder if well I'm gonna take the time
out to do the same these moves are being
played primary reason to preserve our
queen bishops from these knight h4
Knight h5 ideas picking up the bishop
pair so now what
what's this Knight gonna do I'm seeing
the C file opening up and me being able
to play to a 3-2 control c1 and having
that in will mean that the rooks find it
very difficult to contest the open file
in fact right now if rook c1 is played I
win
Tyrael okay if c1 was played because I
could capture and then Bishop here to
here the rook is out of squares ah what
is the big idea black is ready to do
what I don't know what's the what's the
best plan here to run with what would I
really do if I had an hour to think
about this I have to figure something
out
let's see what do I do you're thinking
about a lot of things right now a real
lot interesting rook c8 comes to mind
and what else rook c8 C takes D mmm
a4 actually is another one I'm gonna go
with a a 5 excuse me just so what just
so there's no capture pond push and then
this push I don't I don't want to have
that happen I think I think we could be
seeing that I don't I'm not so sure
about that move now this is just a
tactical vulnerability and we also have
this fork available quite weakening but
um net some stuff and what else
yeah this is that's they're certainly
going to be an improvement with that one
I think in the meantime I'm gonna go
with this rook maybe something will
still happen with this a rook being here
yeah let's take what's what's gonna
happen here what's the worst that can
happen can I actually just go to
double-up right now hmm
double up what is that even leading to
how would I take first ah no no I take
right now and then I'm on this pond so
pond takes like this is needed but now
I'm in a spot to play Bishop here and be
really annoying in fact I could win
material could work myself into a slight
pin but I do have this a4 move available
to support my eventual bishop on b3 now
if Bishop takes to hit my queen and
defend the bishop runs the risk of
getting trapped because I play Queen c7
and then all of a sudden this move is
available so that's what we're seeing
Queen c7 pawn pushes the threat the
center has been given up and now we have
that little of interesting okay
interesting idea
good game very very good game we have
here
this is a weak point I really don't want
to let's do this I don't want to allow
it takes night here and then the night
getting to this square that's a giant
pain Bishop does well to just go all the
way back and and then what maybe
actually I could take play here I don't
know this is tough right here just might
come back over to the D file maybe I'm
maybe I'm regretting bringing the the
King rook over here I would like much
rather have the Queen rook and then the
other up playing to d8 what now
jeez no I don't know what to do here
pretty tight here with the time d-4d 4
and that's dropping a pun what about
just this I'm gonna go with this I have
to I've read I wish it was the other
rook that I have played here then it was
the rooks were both been doing something
on the DNC files but and again I'm
reluctant to take on this square because
of the bishop just having maybe a really
nice post I am opposite this quaint
opposite this Queen right now and this
is the other thing since this tension
since this capture didn't come right now
now I could change the structure yet
again and maybe start to push the white
minor pieces around and oh man
pawn push here Bishop takes pawn in
between move
captured upon push there's there's too
many pieces on this point I'm gonna try
this even though I'm dropping material
gotta try that and just go here and keep
pressure on that Bishop I think I want
to do this Bishop back pawn push okay
let's come back here and well I don't
even have that available now
ouch now the knight is hitting me and
that pond very good very good in between
moves that we're seeing right here I'm
not so sure about that one but those
other ones let's do this 19 seconds I
don't have any time this Knight needs to
get out of there
gotta put pressure on this night why am
I not going quick enough my opponent is
Shirley I opened this up here they are
going to be doing what looking
improvements should I could grab that
pawn oh that pounds gonna push 14
seconds I got to go clicker pawn push my
my king needs to get over here ten
seconds
ready here look up being a pin they're
gonna really take gonna really take time
burners
clock situation they're gonna give me
the rook
just gotta go my king o'clock where's
the clock clock oh my goodness
oh man that was way too close barely
barely barely barely barely uh what a
giant rat race that was right at the end
there
ha ha ha ha bebop thank you so much yes
that is something I was saying in the
tournament I did once again I wasn't
breathing I feel like I just hold my
breath and ah very good game I should
not have gotten that let me see let me
see let me see what resistance right
here there was my opponent was being
incredibly stubborn credibly stubborn
and playing well ok so ok well the night
move okay I'm sure that's already known
it went there and that just comes back
not a whole lot is accomplished maybe
there's a slight improvement with what
rook I should be playing to c8 maybe I
shouldn't have taken that night I don't
know I thought I was alright and then c4
is played and I think white is doing ok
maybe this move is no good this is a
slick move right here
maybe ah ok wait maybe I should be
taking on e3 but then again the Queen
can recapture so I don't know yeah and I
totally forgot about that the suggestion
thanks for reminding me last warrior 10
about the flipping of the board this
Knight move is good alright it's just it
doesn't take right away
you take right away then I could just
push I don't have to worry about my epon
getting captured and that's exactly what
happened nice in-between moves right
here bishop moves boom if I take to try
to do this take and then take the
bishop it's the palm that recaptures and
then it's on my queen
so another in-between move and then I
think this could just be taken right now
you're actually on it twice so you get
you could just chop that guy up right
now and it's a lot cleaner good defense
in a tight position then we're just
getting into a wild time scramble and I
do
I don't stand better here not at all
look at that it's just all strung
together things are good and I just
barely had enough gas in my mouth right
there door towards the end